once upon a time a text to image AI art
generator was tasked with creating a
humanoid robot reading the Wall Street
Journal
sitting on a yellow bench actually there
were lots of different kinds of robots
who like to sit and read the paper
but only one of these robots is actually
real well a real human under a real
robot suit you're real right I am real
the rest of these robots were created by
artificial intelligence using text to
image generators but how do they work
with new tools like open ai's Dolly 2
and stability ai's dream Studio you can
type in a phrase and out comes an image
nothing in these generated images you're
looking at right now is copied and
pasted from Google Images or some photo
agency but how does the quality compare
to real photos
we came up with a challenge to test the
limits of AI photo generation and to see
if it can compete with humans
or in our case a real photographer and a
real man named Peter kokis oh am I lined
up everything uh with his real elaborate
and handmade robot suit which takes an
hour to put on
[Music]
what does this mean about telling real
from fake on the internet I'm gonna
explain it all with the help of
this guy
I don't think he's actually going to be
that much help
let's start with how this works
both Dolly 2 and dream Studio provide a
simple text box you say whatever comes
to mind say a photo of a robot in the
forest with a balloon then both systems
take a few seconds to generate some
pretty accurate and funny images
you might think oh the system is just
looking at images of robots and balloons
and putting them together but no
in the background your text is sent to
open AI or stability AI where there are
powerful artificial intelligence has
learned to make sense of that text and
translate it into completely original
images how did it learn what is what by
looking at billions of labeled images
think of it like flash cards the AI sees
those all and starts to learn that many
sci-fi robots have eyes and boxy heads
and a square stomach same with balloons
it learned that most balloons are this
shape and have strings on them and it
even has this little tie thing
through deep learning it not only knows
that that's a robot and that's a balloon
but it knows the relationship between
two distinct objects so it automatically
puts the balloon in the robot's hand
just like I knew to put the balloon in
his hand
on the shoe or at least Dolly knew to
put the balloon in a hand dream Studio
was pretty confused by the whole robot
balloon thing creating basic images is
just the start of what you can do with
these tools if I wanted to take a
Polaroid of this real robot sitting by
the pool drinking a beer smile I need to
get an instant camera perfect and a beer
Wall Street Journal and a beer
yeah this is going to be the keeper
or I could just type in a humanoid robot
sitting by the pool drinking beer taken
with a Polaroid camera the systems
understand different art and photography
Styles so you can do things like fixing
the office printer in the style of a
medieval painting or an Andy Warhol
style painting of a bunny rabbit wearing
sunglasses realistic photographs are
definitely one of the hardest challenges
for these systems take a high quality
photograph of a robot walking a Cavapoo
no browser come on our photos turned out
great
Dolly on the other hand had an idea of
what a Cavapoo looked like
but the rest was uh yeah
and I have no idea what's going on here
with Dream Studios creation now here is
one of the coolest tricks Peter can you
put your hand in like this for me okay
then I can take this shot upload it to
Dolly and add in whatever I'd like in
this area with a feature called in
painting
and then you can export all those Stills
and make something like this
so in real life or even in an AI
generated image these scenes are pretty
fun a robot doing some everyday things
but what if you wanted to make something
not as fun maybe something gruesome or
based on a real life event or a real
life public figure say Joe Biden eating
a cupcake open ai's Dolly will
immediately restrict searches like that
as the company prevents searches with
names of public figures and various
hateful or harmful words searches for
other names do work like this is what it
thinks of Joanna Stern in space
when I put that Joe Biden prompt into
dream Studio it generated this image
stability ai's founder Ahmad mustak said
he saw no reason to restrict the ability
to generate images of public figures now
say you try a photograph of a terrorist
attack Dolly didn't generate any really
believable images but it did conduct the
search dream Studio generated clearer
images with guns and fire if you look
closely you can see issues with the
quality but let's face it people don't
always look so closely on social media
this all leads to the bigger Tech
question how are we going to be able to
tell the difference between the real or
the fake or the AI generated images on
the internet open ai's policies
encourage users to indicate that content
is AI generated it also places this
watermark in the bottom right of every
image but it can easily be cropped out
stability AI doesn't require any
crediting right now another way to tell
the real from the fake is quality it
depends on what you need a realistic
photo well you're still probably going
to need a photographer and props like we
had today
don't worry but quick compelling
graphics and illustrations for a
presentation website or more this would
do the trick and Microsoft is even
incorporating Dolly into its new
designer app and Bing image Creator
website bottom line AI art tools are
getting real good real fast but your AI
generated robots won't be able to
explain the art behind their creation
those are the lids look trash cans armor
plated butt cheeks